so I want to preface what this video
isn't and what this video is this video
is not one of those articles you read on
huffpa that tell you how awesome you are
how like you know unicorns exist a
fantasy world don't worry about it women
you don't need men this isn't it let me
tell you what this is this is a video
coming from a guy who was 22 23 year old
Playboy that would go to Vegas 26 times
a year I partied religiously and then
eventually I became a high valued man I
realized my value in the marketplace and
I stopped playing and I wanted to wipe
and build a family and that transition I
went through now a couple things not a
marriage counselor not a psychologist
I'm not a therapist I'm simply sharing
my philosophies with you some which is
going to piss you off you're going to be
upset but this is a video specifically
for both men looking to go out there and
be a high value man and for women saying
I would like to find a high value man
having said that let's get right into it
[Music]
okay so ladies first thing you've got to
know is whose life do you want to model
there are a few different options you
have one do you want to be one of those
women that says I don't need a man I'm
independent I make my own money I'm a
girl boss I'm a girl this I'm a I read
these books written by women who've been
divorced five times if that's who you
want to be fantastic that's one model
the other one is you know honestly I
just want to find somebody who is Rich
successful and I want them to be the
husband the money maker I don't want to
work I want to stay home I want to just
have kids and that's all I want to do no
problem the other one could be well I
want to model after these women who are
going out there partying hardcore yeah
maybe they're single moms and they've
had three kids four kids by four
different men but they've had a time of
their lives you can model that life as
well or the last one maybe I don't know
Pat I kind of have my own identity I
have my own interests I have my own
career but I know I want to have a man
who is the alpha of the family who is
the high value men I'm not trying to
compete with them I want to be a
co-pilot he's the leader in the area of
our family where we're going and I'd
like to build something like that with
them fantastic you got choices and by
the way I'm sure there's a lot of
different options on who you want to
model after out of those for a woman you
get to pick and choose it's your
prerogative you're an adult you choose
now before you go out there looking for
high value men it's very important for
you to know how they're wired if you
don't know how they're wired you don't
know how to talk to them you don't know
how to find them I want to give a quick
shout out to our sponsor gold look if
there's one thing we agree on you and I
if you follow this content this we
believe future looks bright right we
think everything's going to work itself
out we just don't know how the economy
is going to be today because you don't
control the fed you don't control the
stock market you don't control the
government you had one vote so we make
the right decision not knowing what's
going to happen to the economy next so
whether it's stocks bonds real estate
crypto cards art or gold my biggest
suggestion is over the years I've always
had gold because I believe you don't
know what's going to happen gold hedge
is great again against inflation these
are strange times with inflation gold
hedge is great against a drop of a Fiat
as a currency all of those things are
way of hedging and protecting yourself
against the laws we looked at a lot of
different companies and gold to team up
with this took a couple years for us but
my friends who used to work at goldco
that I've known for 15 years told me
they're very credible company they're
great at what they do they deliver we
made reference calls and we chose to
team up with these guys they got
thousands of positive views of people
that have done business with them so if
you are considering buying some gold or
silver give our partner at goldco call
today to learn more about protecting
your savings and as a valuetainment
viewer you could get up to ten thousand
dollars in free silver that's right ten
thousand dollars in free silver so when
it comes on to Precious Metals
reputation matters that's why we chose
gold coal give them a call or click on
the link below goco.com forward slash
pbd so let's go through 10 different
things on how high value men are number
one high valued men have many options
you are not the only option they have a
lot of options they generally could be
talking to four five six seven different
women at the same time this doesn't mean
they're being promiscuous with everybody
but they have a lot of options it's
tough to find High valued man high
valued men are very very attractive it's
like the hottest girl in high school how
many men were chasing her High valued
man 28 years old 26 years old 35 years
old a lot of women are chasing him as
well number two when it comes down to
high valued men these are not desperate
men they have a lot of options the last
thing you're going to feel from is
desperation so if you miss that 22 year
old guy that was all over you Clinging
On you you're not going to get it from
these types of men if you want that
they're out there if you want something
like this you're probably not going to
get that from them number three this is
tough one to embrace their marketability
and their value is just going to go up
the more they age the more they succeed
the more they win their marketability
and value is going to keep going up so
you just got to keep that part of mind
there's not going to be declining
there's just constantly going to be
increasing the better they get the wiser
they get the more they succeed number
four they don't chase they attract so
meaning they don't mind courting because
they want that they want to court they
want to go through that process but
they're not Chasers so you know the
whole thing up you know let me do this
three calls he did this I can't call him
back I can't pick up if he does this
they don't play the chasing game they're
constantly attracting good people in
their lives they're not turned on by
games number five they're typically very
confident this doesn't mean they don't
have any insecurities this doesn't mean
they walk on water this doesn't mean
they don't have any anxieties or
different things like that they may you
they may never share it with you but
you're gonna get a feeling being around
them that they're very very confident
why because to get that level of natural
confidence takes years and years of
hours to put into to believe you are
valuable that you produce that type of
confidence number six they take care of
their body this doesn't mean they're all
bodybuilders with six packs but
generally a high value mandate exercise
they have a decent diet they don't fool
around when it comes down to that
doesn't mean it's Perfection but they do
take care of their body so they expect
their women to also take care of their
body number seven they're not needy
they're not clingy they're not
constantly seeking your approval and
some want that some want their meant to
constantly be seeking their approval
you're generally not going to get a lot
of that from a high value man number
eight they have life goals they're going
places they have a vision they want to
go out there and do something big so if
you are expecting this person to be at
home at five o'clock every night because
that's what your dad did the question
you have to ask yourself is you may love
your dad but was your dad a high value
man if the answer is no he was just a
good man it's very different than a high
value man that's got big goals in their
lives that they're in the hunt with you
can't say well I want them to be like my
dad and be home at five o'clock but I
want them to be thinking big there's a
big conflict there you have to
understand that part number nine they
take responsibility if they're going to
screw up they're going to take response
if this is a real man that's a real
leader with the right character they
take responsibility when they screw
things up and they'll generally improve
last but not least you have to know when
you do become a high value man you've
already been through a lot of different
relationships you know the game you see
the signs they understand certain red
flags yeah I don't know about this and
they know when you're faking it or
acting too much to make sure you seem
perfect they've been through that as
well so they're not turned on by those
games they know the game they understand
the game they play the game they just
want to retire away from the game
because they want to have a family they
have bigger plans with a person that
they want to run with so understand that
part that they're very clear about how
the game goes so now before I get into
the 20 rules of young woman when it
comes down to dating high value men you
got to know a couple things there's
different places that we meet people
nowadays right and it's very different
than when it was in your 2000 or 1995
today there's Tinder and Bumble there's
bars and clubs there's business where
you work at through friends and church
right now there's a statistic that came
out talking about what type of
percentages of a relationship and
marriages work out the most here's what
it said on study they did based on 2000
different people the article is titled
relative strangers the importance of
social capital for marriage the study
found out 12 percent of couples who meet
online get divorced within the first
three years of marriage compared to two
percent of couples who meet through
friends and family and after seven years
these statistics are roughly 17 and 10
percent so now the reason why this is
important as well is is to know when
it's online dating there's only so much
a person can learn about you you know if
it's through Friends Church different
places you're able to learn more about
this person because you can ask grandson
what do you know about her what do you
know about him what can you tell him
about him so also know where you're
marketing yourself or where you're
looking for if you're going to Tinder to
find a husband just know what he's
looking for you should not be surprised
if he comes in asking you day one to go
home with them because Tinder is
typically the expectation is one now
some people say you're wrong I met my
husband on Tinder we've been together
for six years I don't solve my success
in life based on Exceptions there are
exceptions to everything I want higher
odds of success and the higher odds of
successes if you your day through Tinder
and Bumble the higher likelihood of
getting a divorce is a lot harder than
going through friends and other places
so just keep that part of mind having
said that let's get right into 20 rules
for young women when it comes down to
dating high value men let's get right
into it number one if you see men as the
enemy good luck finding a high value man
simple as that you cannot see man as the
enemy why do I say this a lot of times
mothers who went through a divorce and
maybe married a man who didn't treat
them well they indirectly put that
mindset into their daughters their
daughters at six years old seven years
old 10 years old 15 years old have heard
how many times that Mom has talked smack
about the dad eventually the daughter
becomes a 22 year old woman who sees man
as the enemy if you see them as enemy
good luck finding a high valued man
number two if you do land a high valued
man and you start dating him the job has
just begun this isn't about oh my God
I'm dating Larry do you realize how
awesome he is he's a high value man
let's see if you can keep him let's see
if you can keep them just because you
got them doesn't mean you got them
forever this is work you know it's not
like a you're good for three months and
we can act for three months six months
later the truth shows up a year later
wait a minute who am I dating here and
then eventually you're like maybe you
dated them for a year maybe for a year
and a half but you can't keep a guy like
that you got to make sure you can keep a
high value man not just attract a high
value man which means it's work both
sides it's work we got to do our part
you gotta also do your part number three
body count Matters by the way men may
not tell you but it matters okay when a
person I'm doing a job interview with
them and they tell me in their resume
they've had 20 jobs in the last 10 years
I don't want to hire them because
there's a reason why they've had 20 jobs
in 10 years okay they can't keep
somebody together the other part you
know how when you go out there and
you're just hooking up having a lot of
one night stands left and right thinking
no one's going to tell anybody
a man who hooks up with you for one
night and you say let's keep it between
us his level of loyalty is zero to you
meaning he'll brag about hooking up with
you to his friends and his peers because
he owes you nothing there is no such
thing as a one-night stand keeping it
secret it's going to lead to other
people so if you do that constantly
people are going to know a high value
man is going to be like you know what
I'm gonna pump the brakes here you're
not for me I like you a lot but not for
serious relationship you ever heard a
saying a woman can tell within the first
30 seconds to a minute whether they're
going to sleep with a man or not you
ever heard that part before a man will
also tell very quickly whether this is a
girlfriend that they're going to show
off to their friends or family or if
this is just somebody they're gonna have
fun with okay they will know very very
quickly on how you carry yourself when
it comes down to having class you either
have class or you don't have class one
can't act classy here's what I mean by
back in the days when I was 21 22 I
would I would go to these Financial
meetings acting like I'm well off
financially I'm doing very good for
myself maybe maybe I can fake it for
five minutes maybe 30 minutes but about
an hour later the client found out this
guy's broke we're in DSW Shoes we're in
a three-day soup broker suit and Ross
Thai he has no clue what he's talking
about this guy doesn't have any money
work on having real class real values
real principles because there's no need
to act it's real so this next one's not
going to be very popular but it is what
it is so let's just say you have a high
value man that you really like and he's
in a relationship for about a year you
come in and somehow some way he likes
you you become the side chick he drops
the girl he's with to be with you so now
he is with you six 12 months later don't
be surprised and upset if he's got a
side chick this relationship started off
with you being a side chick you can't be
not surprised saying I can't believe
he's got a side chick you just may not
be the person that he's willing to
settle down with you just may be
somebody that he just wants to have fun
with so look just because somebody's a
high value man doesn't mean this person
wants to settle down and get married
today maybe their timeline is five years
three years eight years ten years
there's a part of it that's on you to
see if there's any signs that this man
is eventually going to want to do that
or if they're just having fun okay and
and that part there's not a manual to it
there's not a book to read about it it's
purely intuition it's got you'll know
about it when you get that feeling trust
it but don't jump to conclusion too
early maybe give it a month or two or
three before you say no this one's not
going anywhere I do want to have a
family right now I can't wait for this
guy my time is coming make your decision
move on but just know it's going to come
down to your intuition this next one is
a little amateurish but a lot of women
do this and I don't recommend it never
brag about how great your man is in bed
okay never I can't tell you from a
personal story I had one she would do
that all her cousins would call me and
wanted to find out what it was like I
don't know if that makes sense don't
brag about how great your man is in bed
if he's great in bed and if she's great
in bed keep it to yourself it's nobody
else's business this next part is
something you've heard a million times
you know you control you control
everything because he has what you want
right he has what you want you set the
tone you set the standard uh and this
well you know this is no longer the 60s
who cares about the first date you
choose what the standards are but the
sooner you get intimate it just means
you don't value it that much and a man
May sit there and say well that was kind
of really quick how many other people
were you this quick with value take your
time before you decide to just give it
up that easily I think it was Steve
Harvey that says wait 90 90 days I don't
know what timeline he put that book that
he said Think Like a Lady act like a man
or something act like a Lady Think Like
a Man great book if you haven't read it
read the book his timeline I believe is
90 days but do protect it don't give it
up that easily this next one about only
fans it's so funny I'm doing a business
meeting in Long Beach California this
one girl gets up drop that gorgeous she
asked me questions times are really hard
on real estate I'm going through this
I'm going through it I'm going through
this and I look at her and I said look
um there's a lot of people right now
that are being tempted to make money
through on defense she starts crying
okay like literally she starts crying so
when she cries you already kind of have
an idea she was also either tempted or
she did it because it's easy money to
make when you're that beautiful go make
your fifty hundred thousand dollars a
month right it is a choice you can make
but there's a very different big
difference between you doing that those
things are permanent you have to explain
it to your kids to your husband to
everybody when that becomes public
unfortunately back in the day save
somebody that's something like only fans
that wasn't a camera where everything's
going to be public social media
Instagram it's a very different ballgame
today a man who has another girl that's
on only fans may have fun with her may
even be interested in having fun with
her but it's different when it's coming
down saying I want to build a family
with this person again
well that's not true I know somebody
that did this I'm going with odds I'm
not going with the exception make sense
so this next one is very interesting I I
have seen a lot of men who are high
value they've been around been around
the for very long time but I've also
seen when a guy's dating a girl and then
publicly she makes a comment to
embarrass him that's a very personal
embarrassing comment and then a month
later he breaks up with his like she
just doesn't understand the Dynamics
that you never publicly embarrass your
man especially if he's a high octane
high value man you just don't publicly
embarrass them when you do that do it
privately hey babe I don't like how you
wait the way you handled yourself that
was not cool have the conversation with
them do not do it publicly uh they will
not that will not go well so you have a
high valued man this doesn't mean every
pressure needs to be on him he knows you
bring a lot of value to the table as
well okay so what could that thing be
could be finances could be family it
could be faith it could be Fitness it
could be relationships it could be a lot
of different things but you have to
bring your own Dynamic to the table as
well that is an area of strength that's
not his so what are some areas you bring
to the table you can have some
confidence from that area when they say
this is what I do well I'm going to be
able to do this I'm going to be able to
do this I'm going to be able to do this
fantastic trust me a man is going to sit
there and say that's very valuable to me
man I'm so glad she brings that to the
table because I don't listen reputation
matters I understand we hear about you
know repetitions what other people say
about you about characters who you
really are your reputation matters when
it comes down to dating high value men
men are going to call around and say
well can you tell me about her what are
you going to do about her he's going to
call around and if he doesn't
he's not doing his part the high value
man that I know is going to be calling
and saying hey you know this girl has
she been this has she done that has she
done that and are people going to be
talking I remember one time she dated
that guy that one time we went out she
was drunk and she did this and she did
that okay cool you're not expecting for
Perfection because if any girl that
seems a little too perfect she's
probably got a lot of things filled in
the closet generally there's going to be
something but protect your reputation
because it's going to follow you never
bash your exes it doesn't matter what it
is never bash your exes if you bash your
last three X's I'm gonna be the fourth
one and I'm not interested in that hey
how come your last relationship didn't
work honestly we were just on different
pages you know he wasn't somebody I saw
myself being with long term good guy his
own thing not interested we want
separate ways and uh you know I'm just
not you know don't sit there and say he
was this he was an idiot he was a
he was of this not attractive don't say
it in a way where she's like you sound
like you kind of are interested in but
don't also go out there and Bash on the
guy talking about how big of a loser he
is your social media profile laws matter
if I go on your social media profile and
I'm like okay there's one butt picture
two butt picture three butt picture man
she's like all over the place what is
this oh my God there's a bong there's
this there's that yeah I'm gonna have
some fun with her no one's gonna meet
this girl this is just a girl that I'm
gonna have fun with so protect your
social media profile because they're
gonna look if you have interest in
competing with your man and beating him
like you know what I'm going to do
better than him in business and I'm
gonna do this
don't expect to find an alpha male you
know high value man you're probably
gonna end up with a beta milk it's gonna
be okay with you beating them because
Alphas they have no interest in
competing with their wives
they want to lead their girls that's
what they want to do so this next one oh
my God I can't believe you're saying
this you're so old school uh men are not
interested in you having male friends
well Pat How about if it's just one no
he's gay I don't care he may change his
mind Pat come on Pat you can't say that
I'm telling you
even if he tells he doesn't care he
cares okay but I've known him from high
school from second grade from first
grade even worse
you're mine I'm Yours let's roll I'm not
interested in you talking to other men
wow this is so extreme you know you're
such a machismo saying this don't worry
about it I'm just telling you I'm around
these types of men all the time they're
not interested and you're having too
many male friends
and too many is one if you and this man
date for a few months and it's getting
serious in his mind at one point if he
wants to get to the next level with your
marriage engagement all this stuff he's
asking what kind of a mother are you
going to be he'll be watching you and
the way he'll judge what kind of a
mother you'll be is how you treat him
okay how you treat your younger siblings
these are ways that they're watching to
see what kind of a mother you one day be
because that's something they value a
lot so if he doesn't take you in public
places around friends and family
he likes you for fun
but he doesn't want to be seen in public
with you as his girlfriend okay may
sting may hurt
but many men have done that I've done
that myself
fun a few months I'm with a girl no one
ever knew about it because I just knew
we're never going to be long-term
together we're just having fun so you
know this whole thing about virginity
you know no I'm not telling you to be a
virgin and all this stuff I'm not
telling you that you choose to do that
based on your faith that's up to you
many do I'm not telling you that but
what I'm saying to you is the following
so a guy goes out with two different
girls one girl's like oh my god I've
never been to this restaurant before Oh
my god I've never been to this Spa
before oh wow this first time ever I was
on a private jet I've never flown first
class before I loved Santorini this was
amazing Cinque Terre great never been to
Dubai amazing so the guy's like oh yes
yes he's feeling good because he wants
to give you the world right show you the
world right the other one he goes I was
here two months ago honestly the food
wasn't that good tonight
okay hey yeah this Resort is good but I
like to Spa more in Beverly Hills oh my
God you are so annoying go find somebody
else I'm not the guy for you now let's
just say she has been around and she
says I've been to this restaurant before
but oh my God I had such a good time
with you thank you so much for taking me
here tonight oh this Spa what a great
experience it was tonight thank you so
even if you have be grateful say thank
you don't act like you've been around
all over the place because all he's
thinking is it's probably been with five
other guys that had money what am I
going to be doing she's been around okay
just keep that part of mind he's
thinking he may not tell you this but
he's thinking about it because many
times we're thinking a lot of thoughts
but we don't tell you but we're thinking
it so there you go if you're upset if
you're happy if you're glad you watched
it it's my perspective okay whether you
like it or not these are some of my
philosophies now if you've never seen a
video 20 rules for young men click here
to watch that video take care everybody
bye-bye bye-bye
[Music]